from those around
i heard
oh god oh god
my
peace be unto you the same greeting of
all the messengers of god
and we are here trying to help you
understand the most misunderstood way of
life in the world today islam
which is not a new way of life brought
by muhammad it's the same way of life
that was taught by all the messengers of
god calling you
to the submission of the one god
worshiping him alone and not his
creation
so you've already learned something and
you're going to continue to learn
something
all we ask is that you have an open
heart and open mind and be ready for our
next guest in our next topic
we'll be talking about depth some of the
details
because this is an appointment that we
all have and we want to get ready we
want to know how to get ready and we
want to know what to expect
and there's nothing out there like islam
that clarifies and gives you these
details so sit tight
you don't want to go nowhere right back
on the dean show
maybe it's just to break the ice salon
how are you it's like i just saw you
so all right we're gonna get straight
down to the top we're gonna be talking
about dev this is something serious
we don't want nobody to run and get
scared now but this is something serious
so we're we're happy enough that you
tuned in and you come to learn about
islam and to learn about the way of life
that god almighty wants you to live by
and we're very excited that we have you
a person who's memorized the whole quran
who knows the authentic traditions of
the last and final messenger who sent
to mankind so we don't have a
a car mechanic uh i say uh teaching us
this deen this way of life you're a
specialist and
we want to talk about the details and i
think this just another evidence because
islam has
evidence on top of evidence on top of
evidence to prove to the sincere person
that this is from the creator this is
not man-made
so talk to us about death
something that we have an appointment
with
talk to us about that moment of death
the moment of death which everybody
fears
and everybody that thinks about death
brings some pain in the heart
and that's why most of the people they
ignore this fact and they want to live a
life of
being away from it of unforgetfulness so
that they don't feel the misery
but whether we like it or not whether we
run away from it or not
we have to face it as allah
that you are fleeing away from he has to
meet you
he's already set his way out as if this
is the case
and you're going diligently every day
towards the last
and final rest in this life and death is
coming your way
so some point you have to meet it it
might be right this second
maybe after a month a year allah
subhanahu wa
that's why it's not just for those who
are sick some people die in car
accidents some people die just
like that with a heart attack whatever
the means are many many many
but the the one thing that is for sure
death is coming
so because of that and because allah is
the most merciful
he mentioned the quran and the sunnah
the prophet saws some very specific
details
so that the believers would know exactly
what they're going
going to face although saying it and
hearing it
is nothing compared to seeing it with
one one's eyes
so first of all it would never bring
misery just to make this clear
because the one that brings the joy and
the misery is the creator of the heavens
and earth and he's the one that made
this place of happiness is in the heart
and the most happiest man that was
present on the face of earth was prophet
muhammad sallallahu alaihi
and allah said about them didn't we make
your
your your rest spacious meaning that
you're happy in this life although he is
the one that ordered us
to remember death much so if you
remember death much
and you are steadfast on the religion of
islam you will be the most happiest
person on this face of earth and in the
after
at the moment of death the prophet peace
be upon him
said in a very long and lengthy hadith
and i won't say the whole thing
but he said in in this long hadith in
details what's going to happen to the
person
and he divided the people into believers
and disbelievers
yeah and he said when the person is
about to start his hereafter because
he after starts with the moment of death
and he's departing from this life
if if he's a believer the angels will
come to him
from the heavens and with bright faces
and they would sit with him as long as
his eyes can see
and this is reality this is more real
than the fact that i'm sitting here and
i'm looking at you and you're looking at
me
so at that moment he would see the angel
sitting lining up
all the way to the to what his eyes can
see
and then the angel of death there's an
angel responsible for taking the souls
of the human being
the angel of death will come down and he
would sit in front of him
and he would order the sword and he
would say to the soul
to the believing soul go out with
to the mercy and the pleasure of allah
so the soul will come out as the prophet
sallam said in the meaning of which
like a drop of water coming out from the
opening of a water skin
see how easy and soft that happens this
is the soul of the believers come
out in such an easy way so once the soul
comes out of the believer
the hadith says again this is not
opinions this is the sayings of the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
revelation from allah
once the soul come out the rest of the
angels they don't leave it in the hands
of the angel of death they would take it
and they would wrap it in a coffin from
jannah from paradise
that has the best fragrance and the best
smell
and they would take it and they would go
and elevate
to the heavens with the soul and every
heaven that they would go to
sky levels we know that there's seven
heavens or seven skies
they would take the permission and the
angels would say who is that person
with the best names that he used to be
called in this world
why because of the great smell that they
are smelling
and the great thing that that is
happening so they would say it's so and
so the son of so and so
the best names that used to be named in
this world they go from one heaven to
the other
did they reach the seventh one and then
allah would say
that right the deeds of my slave in the
highest level
and this is for the believers and return
his soul back to the earth
because i promised them that from the
earth i created them
and from the earth they shall return and
from the earth they shall be resurrected
so the soul will come down into the body
again in the earth but not
just in the same way that we are living
now and then
after he is buried then and people
depart
from his grave and the prophet
sallallahu salaam he said
that he would hear the footsteps of the
people when they're departing
the dead person then after they leave
the angels of death
or two angels will come to him and these
two angels will make him sit in a way
that allah knows best we're not talking
about physical things here
and they would ask him three questions
and this is what
is very important for us to realize now
that this is what we prepare ourselves
for do we have answers
to these three questions or not and the
answer is not just what we
know is how our life was they would ask
him who is your lord
what is your religion and who is the
messenger
that was sent to you and the believers
they would say when they asked who is
your lord they
he would say allah the creator of the
heavens and earth and who is what is
your religion he would say
submission to the creator of the heavens
and the earth which is islam
and who is the rep your prophet he would
say prophet muhammad
that moment he will be opened a gate in
front of him
to the hellfire to the hellfire and it
will be said to him
this was supposed to be your place if
you would have been a disbeliever
but it was replaced for you by another
place
and then a gate to the paradise will be
open to him
and the fragrance and the goodness from
the paradise will come into him
and it will be said to him that this is
your place when the day of judgment
would occur but not now
so at that moment he would say oh allah
allah make the hour occurs he wants it
to happen quickly
so that i can go back to my family and
my wealth meaning to enter the paradise
and the total opposite is for the
disbelievers and let me just
start by i know i'm taking too long but
for the disbelievers the prophet sallam
gave the example
that it would make it more closer into
our minds he said when a disbeliever is
about to die
the angels of punishment will come down
unto him
and they are the most horrific looks
these angels creation of allah and
the angel of death also they would sit
in front of him
as far as his eyes can see the angel of
death will come
and then he would say ordering the soul
to come out and he would say
come out to the punishment and the anger
of the creator of the heavens and the
earth
because you had committed injustice
against your own self
when you did not fulfill the purpose of
your life the prophet peace be upon him
said at that moment
the soul would scatter all over the
the body of this disbeliever doesn't
want to come doesn't want to come out
so what happens the angel of death would
snatch it
would pull it so hard that
it would be so much of course painful
and the prophet saws
gave the example that it as if it's
touring the person
tearing it tearing him like you have a
piece of iron
in a wet wool what happens to it it just
tears it apart is that from being
attached to this world and not having
been prepared for the next life
neglecting your obligation state of
forgetfulness in the state of disbelief
yeah and and it becomes all over the
place it does not
see the remember the first example it
comes out like a drop from a water skin
very easy and very soft right but the
disbeliever
he had to do this to it and then when it
comes out the angels would wrap it in a
coffin
that is from the half fire that has the
worst smell to it yeah
and when it's try to go up into the
heavens it won't be able to and the
angels for the first heaven it would say
who is this
nasty and and bad smell yeah human
beings it would be said so and so the
son of so and so with the worst names
that he used to be named
in this world and then it would say or
something
would be said that bring him back to
this earth and it will be thrown into
the earth
again and when the angels would come to
the person after they depart after they
burying him
the two angels will come and make him
sit and ask him same three questions
who is your lord that person would say
ha
ha this is what the hadith says i do not
know
i heard people saying things you didn't
prepare he was not preparing himself
he was busy with the sin and the
disobedience of the creator of them he
heard people saying
come worship the creator of the heavens
and the earth alone they advised them
they told them so many times
but he was busy with intoxicating
himself and he was
he will be asked what is your religion
he would say i do not know i heard
people saying things who is your
messenger he would still
not able to answer although he might
know it
but the tongue would only speak of what
was present in the heart and then
it will be opened for him again to
paradise to jannah
and it will be said to him that this was
supposed to be your place
if you were a believer see how much
regret a person would have
when he sees this and then again to the
how fire will be open and it will be
said to him that this is your place
and all the the bad things will come to
him from the fire and he would say oh my
rob o my lord do not make the hour
occurs
because now he knows that he's going to
the punishment of allah and he has to
live
with this everlasting without no end
because of what because of few years
that a person lived in a state of
disbelief and forgetfulness and let me
just add something
somebody might say isn't that a form of
injustice that a person lives
60 70 years in state of disbelief
and then he has to live everlasting life
in the fire
you know why is that much yeah to answer
this is
for someone that lived and died in the
state of disbelief
he had the intentions while he was
living that if he would live
forever on the face of earth he would
live forever in the state of disbelief
so as a result of this attitude that he
his punishment is everlasting one allah
is the most just
and he would not punish anyone unless
the matter is made clear to him
and as allah says in the quran
we do not punish till we send the
messenger this is the mercy of allah
messengers are being sent and they sent
to tell you oh you human being
you believe in god worship him alone and
then you turn away
you worship other than him you live a
life of forgetfulness you don't want to
do nothing with
with being steadfast on the on the
proper submission to the creator of the
heavens and the earth
then do not blame no one but your own
self that's why it's such a serious
matter
the early generations of islam they used
to take this matter so serious
that their whole life is just preparing
themselves to this last moment
of this life because afterwards anything
that we did we have to live with it
everlasting so it's on you now that
person
a muslim might have a non-muslim his
colleague at work and they might be
watching the show
so they might actually be a little more
enthusiastic about doing what they need
to do the simple thing to become someone
who is a believer and the one who can
answer those questions
when death comes when that appointment
comes so you're not like that person in
class who didn't study and the teacher
calls on you
like that that no you can ask
allah is my lord right islam is my way
of life and muhammad is the last and
final messenger
and you show it to your actions tell us
right now how simple it is
so someone doesn't have to be out of the
mercy of his creator
how simple is it what does a person have
to do to be
on the side of the angels when the
angels come and give you those glad
tidings of
come on come on sweet soul you're going
to paradise and your lord
your creator is happy and pleased with
you we want to be on that side
well my sincere advice to anybody that
is watching
stop for some time of this busyness of
your life
and sit and think sincerely and
truthfully
what is the purpose of my life you
believe in god
you believe in the creator of the
heavens and the earth and you have to we
are forced to believe in him of course
in a nice way
because nothing happens by itself and
he's the creator of the heavens and
earth
if you believe in him then you believe
that he's the most perfect
that he's the most merciful he is the
most wise that he is the most powerful
so why should you fear of anyone but him
why should you seek
any hope and reward from anyone but him
he's the most perfect so if you think
for a second about this
and then turn to him sincerely and turn
to him
alone to show you the truth because the
matter is serious
at least it's fair enough if somebody
sitting now
telling you that after death it's either
hellfire or the paradise
it is fair enough for for you that you
take the matter seriously maybe what
he's saying is correct
so think about it sincerely seek help
from the lord of the heavens and the
earth sincerely
and ask him sincerely to show you the
truth and it's also fair enough
that you would go read the quran the
last revelation of allah
nobody is forcing you to do anything
just read it with an open heart a heart
that is searching for the truth
and read the sayings of the prophet
muhammad and ask
and not to live a life of forgetfulness
and not just to depend on the media
to tell you what islam is and what
muslims are go do it yourself
and the book is saved from 1400 years
ago
never been changed read it and see if it
makes sense to you or not if you go
through the steps i don't want to
manipulate anybody or force anybody or
cause anything like that just do it for
yourself
but to live a life of putting it aside
putting it aside i'm okay
i like my way of life that i'm doing now
fooling ourselves
living a life of deception and then when
the moment of death comes the regret
would never benefit yeah you don't need
no money for men or anything right
there's no benefit to you right
right you're not gonna have to come to
me i'll give you anything you give me
anything
okay for your own benefit tell us now
the seriousness of this because
we're busy with accumulating wealth upon
well position upon position
and as you said in one of our prior
shows that
islam encourages for you to be the best
at whatever you do is this correct
correct
so now this is something that is
encouraged to be
educated and to be someone who is the
best in society
and who is beneficial to others
but now if you're neglectful of your
purpose in life and you're just chasing
your whims and desires it's not good
tell us that moment of those three
things that follow you to the grave
and then the two things that come to
argue over the one thing
can you talk about that the prophet
salallahu
he said when a person dies three things
goes with him in his funeral till he's
buried
one stays with him and two go back he
said these three things
are his family his wealth and his deeds
that's
it that's it those are the three things
huh and you find them in the funeral you
find the car of the one that died
is driven yeah going to the grave with
him and his family is with him
and his wealth his family his children
whatever wearing the clothing that he
bought for them
yeah you know his wealth is going with
him but then when he's buried
he does not take his car with him he
don't take that does not take the bank
account in the checkbook with him
he doesn't take nothing what stays with
him is the deeds that he did in this
life and this is what all matters at the
end
and that's why the person should take
this life in such a way that
the most concern to us is to establish
the acts of worship
to be obedient to the creator of the
heavens and the earth and
by the way people have this idea that
religion
is something that make your life
miserable that you have to leave your
status and your wealth
and you have to be among somewhere this
is not in the true religion this is
never be the way of life that allah
wants from us because why did he create
wealth for us why did he create
the beauty on this world just to make it
difficult for us and to make it evil
of course it's not evil it is the beauty
that we're supposed to use
for the purpose of life and we enjoy it
too why would a person
know that everything is permissible
juice and water and everything that for
you to drink but you choose something
that would intoxicate your mind
you left all that is good than pure and
you choose just that one thing that what
makes your life more difficult
even and the same thing with the acts of
worship and so on
so in the religion of islam take it from
me and don't take it from me just
do it for yourself you would never be
miserable in the sense that happiness is
in the heart
everything will fall in place everything
will make sense there's no contradiction
between life of being religious
and being successful in business or
whatever actually the companions of the
prophet saws
they were business people they were not
just some religious
like the religious people and then the
message of the people
and in which the religious freedom
figure manipulate the people
and he's such a holy there's no holiness
in anybody on the face of earth
everybody's responsible for his own
deeds and that we earn this
we do not take it by inheritance or from
lineage we do it with our own actions
buying and selling even is an act of
worship if we do it in the proper way
and we have regulations in this in the
dean of islam honesty being truthful
smiling even in front of someone not to
hurt someone and insult him this is a
good deed this is something that would
take the person to paradise
but with the foundation that has to be
proper and that is to say
which means there is no one you have to
say this with your tongue and your heart
before that
there is no one worthy of worship except
allah the creator of the heavens and
earth the lord of moses and jesus
muhammad and all the messengers of allah
and that prophet muhammad peace be upon
him is the final messenger
if you believe in it don't wait you
never know if death would come
today for you or not and then that would
be your teacher that
last and final messenger correct me if
i'm ever wrong
that this is the same way if you were
living during the time of moses
jesus abraham you would declare this
declaration that there's no god except
the one true god allah
and that moses was his messenger at that
time jesus was the messenger at that
time and etc etc so that same way
correct correct
and then you had to emulate them you had
to follow jesus he was the way the truth
and the light
moses was the way the truth how to get
to god showing you how to
pray to god and worship god is that
correct correct so we have to emulate
the last and final message not worship
any of them
right can you emphasize on this real
quick human being is a human being yeah
flesh and blood eyes and ears and
everything is a human being
he is in need always of the creator of
the heavens and the earth
the creator of the heavens and the earth
is nothing like the human being and this
distinction
has to be clear because it made so many
people fall into the trap of mixing
together yeah
the creator is nothing is the light of
the human being and he's all here
all see yes but the human being is
something else deficient
has deficiency in it always in need of
the creator of the heavens and earth
messengers of allah are the best of the
human beings
the best level and the highest level of
a human being that can he can reach
is to be the more humble to the creator
of the heavens and earth not the one
that would elevate himself to
think that he's the creator of the
heavens and the earth so believing in
this
and knowing that if you study the life
of prophet muhammad and this is another
call for people to do that
his teachings he he would never call the
people to do any evil
his teachings is to live a perfect way
of life
and no matter what you do if it's eating
if it's drinking
if it's what's permissible what's not
permissible it's to make your life a
perfect one not just for the hereafter
but for this life to be a perfect life
if a community would apply it
they would have the happiness in this
life and after it was practiced by the
way
it was never in the books it was
practiced in the time of the early
generations of islam and so on
people embraced islam in the masses if
you look at the
at the map at the time of prophet
muhammad and afterwards
the world map america was not discovered
yet right and you would see
that anywhere the muslims went to people
embrace islam in masses countries
nations
and this is something that is amazing
never happened on the face of earth
when people saw a practical way of life
of being truthful being honest
making sense of everything that they do
they worship and they buy and sell
they are at night like monks and they
weep
and they cry and they stand and they
make worship and in the morning
there are strong men and women acting
and doing things in this life
that would benefit them in this life and
here after there's no separation between
such a thing as religion
and life and all of these types of
things it's all one because it's all the
creation of the creator of that
that makes no sense now this is another
proof that why would
the creator he create us and then take
off and say figure it out on your own
right that there's a system how he wants
you to live and this is the system
submitting
your will to his will now tell us we're
almost out of time a few more points
by implementing submission to the one
god islam the way of life of all the
messengers
one gets peace tranquility and god is
good he only accepts good so the good
talk about
briefly the good of worshiping him alone
the good of
not uh uh using foul language
uh not drinking alcohol doing drugs
gambling prostitution
all these evil vices that only if
someone hears it
if he's sincere with himself you see
like man if i do this stuff it's only
going to make me a better human being
anyway talk about this for a minute
see the heart has a certain quality yeah
it has so much
diversions in it and the only way that
would collect this heart to have this
calmness
and the happiness in it it is the mercy
of allah that he made it in such a way
that a person would never have this
calmness and this happiness
unless he worshipped the creator of the
heavens and the earth
alone and no matter how much a person
is doing in his life he would never
taste this the real meaning of sweetness
and happiness in his life
unless he is worshiping the creator of
the heavens and earth he would always
otherwise
feel there's something missing something
missing something is not right
yeah and this is actually if a person is
truthful with his own self
he would find this that this is true
that's why people run away from religion
why because it doesn't make sense yeah
yeah right
but when it comes look at the muslims in
general you would find in general that
people
have this belief is the same although
there are so much
people are in state of forgetfulness
because of not applying the orders of
allah
but this happiness is present in the
heart if a person worship the creator of
the heavens and the earth
alone because it's his mercy that he
became it became in such a way
and that's why it's mentioned
however good deeds he would live a good
life and one last thing is
if you have a fruit that looks
very unpleasant from the outside yeah
but this thing in the desert i forgot
what it called in english the cactus or
something like this
inside it's very sweet yeah but from the
outside it has horns and thorns and
things like that right so when you see
it from
far away you say this is not good but if
somebody
peeled it and ate it and he says it's
very sweet
yeah right who is the one that would
know
both way of life the one that tasted it
so for you to be away from the religion
of
islam and to say you know it's not good
we didn't taste it
for someone to be in state of
toxications and
prostitution and all these types of
things and someone else repented from
all of this he tasted he has
he know what it means and what it feels
to be in such a state right
and he repented to allah and he now
tasted
the sweetness of faith he is the one to
be asked
what is the best of both yeah but the
one that is still in the
forgetfulness and the and the sins and
so on he doesn't know the other side
so it's not fair if he says it's not no
it's the other side it's just
misery he did not know what it is the
other one is the one that knows both and
how it feels and that's the one
that should be asked and this is what we
need to do taste it and take the means
to it and be patient in doing so
you will get the happiness in this life
in here thank you very much time is out
we got to go i wish we could talk some
more
may allah the creator that heavens
reward you in abundance
i mean thank you and thank you again for
being with us on the dean's show it's
very simple
it's one god worship him alone do what
he wants you to do put your desires this
thing inside you that just
wants this and wants that and you just
can't get enough you know what you'll
never get enough
until the dirt's in your mouth don't let
it come to that be sincere and honest
ask the one who created you to guide you
is the first step
put off chasing all the women in the
good times
and the parties and this and that put it
on hold man do some investigating some
leg work
everything is there it's been saved you
have the living miracle the last and
final revelation sent to mankind the
koran
it's an instruction manual from a to z
how you live is
in accordance with the creator and then
there's nothing left in paradise
it's very simple so it's up to you we're
here to help you
come back and see us every week on the
dean show i hope you got to benefit
and we'll see you next time god willing
inshaallah until then assalamu alaikum
peace
be unto you
bismillah
uh
moon
foreign
foreign
you find one contradiction it can't be
from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best
give up worshiping god is one i will
never give up spreading this message
i hope that you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're going to live
till tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now
the reality of life usually doesn't
sink in until tragedy comes
you get a few bad people the media grabs
a hold of that
and spends it the way they want to
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim and attended our
faith
you